what I'm going to talk about is the
standard API is the machine learning API
so that we have available that you can
start using today to make your
applications smarter so let's take one
step back and talk for a second about
what what machine learning is machine
learning is a method of teaching
computers to recognize patterns based on
examples and experience so it's very
easy for a child to understand the
difference between the picture of a cat
and a picture of a dog but for computers
this is actually very very hard so if
you would start to write rules to
differentiate between a cat and a dog
you have to build a lot of rules and
create a set of rules and pretty much
for every set that you can come up with
anyone can pull out a picture that is
not gonna match the rules that you've
thought of so instead of writing those
rules yourself you want the machine to
learn the rules by themselves and
actually learn over time and have them
become smarter as well and that's what
we've been doing and we have trained
different api's or different models with
a vast amount of data and they're pre
trained and you can use them so as an
example with the cats and dogs this is a
neural net that's one of the mechanisms
for machine learning it gets its inputs
from its raw pixels image points of the
image and with different layers it
learns how to recognize certain small
pieces in the picture such as an edge or
a shape or that maybe the fur is a
little bit fuzzy so the higher you get
in the neural net the higher level of
abstraction the neural net actually
extracts out of the image and at the top
layer there are only two neurons left
we call them neurons because this neural
net is obviously modeled after our own
brains and the two neurons
basically specify is this picture of a
dog or is this picture of a cat and in
this case it is a dog so let's do a
small experiment and try to illustrate
the difficulty of you know not having a
machine learning model learning the
rules and let's see if we can come up
with some rules of ourselves of a
human-powered
image detection all right so let's start
so let's say we want to write some rules
to differentiate between apples and
oranges so what would be a distinctive
feature that you could use to separate
the two types of images and you could
shout out color stem color let's go with
color apple orange greenish orange
orange should work right but what if the
data that you get is not only in color
it's black and white you immediately
have a problem and this is what I meant
with any set that you can bring I can
give you a picture that's probably not
gonna work so how about if you add
another fruit you have to start over
again because now the shape there's a
new shape that is being introduced right
so the more different types of data you
have the more complex your data set or
your rule set has to become okay but
that's fruit right I mean fruit they're
all very similar that's that's that's
actually quite difficult so let's make
two things that are you know you would
never think of as the SD being the same
right so let's say we want to classify
mobs from dogs should be easy right well
maybe not so
so this is very difficult actually I
have to look at some of the pictures and
I'm sure some of you are doing the same
now we're like what is this is this what
is this this is a dog it is a dog
actually so this is difficult right but
it even gets more difficult what if you
want to classify all the images
everything any object you want to
recognize that anybody using Google
photos yeah Google photos is really
really great at this and it's it's
powered by the same vision API that
we're going to look at in a minute
so what if you're not only one of
process images but you also want to
process video as we saw in the keynote
or you have audio or you have
unstructured text that you want to
extract information from so that's the
space and that's the reason why machine
learning is becoming so popular because
it can handle some really really complex
problems so with Google we have
basically two solutions or offerings
that can help you with machine learning
so on the left hand side you will see
our open source library that is the
let's say six years of work that we've
open source now it's called tensorflow
it's the most popular machine learning
library on github
so if you haven't looked at it I
strongly suggest you have a look at it
it's it's very very powerful it's
running many of the machine learning
stuff that we're doing we have cloud
machine learning engine so in tensorflow
you can define your model and you can
specify how to train your model but now
you need to compute in the storage
resources where you actually train it
and believe me training these models
takes a lot of storage and it takes a
lot of compute power a lot of compute
power so probably the best way to do it
is in the cloud and obviously we think
it the best place to do it is in our
cloud and cloud machine machine learning
engine does that it leverages our CPUs
GPUs and the custom-built Tipu's that we
that we've announced also so on the
right hand side
you don't have to do any of that we've
done it for you we have provided the
data we have trained these models and
all you need to do is provide your
sample and we do basically the
classification and tell you what's in
the image right so these are pre-trained
out-of-the-box api's that you can
leverage in your applications with a
single rascal alright let's starts start
with the vision API so the vision API is
as an API that does complex image
recognition through a single call and
one example was already briefly
mentioned in the keynote is real tour
real realtor.com it's a real estate
agent and it's using the vision API in
their mobile application so when you're
looking for houses and you see a house
for sale you can pick up your phone take
a picture or your point your camera at
the sign that's there it will extract
the information and it will pull up all
the information of the house from the
realtor.com website so it's just very
easy for someone just to find the
listing in there on their website so
what are some of the features that are
available in the vision API so the first
most known feature is label detection so
basically the vision API will tell you
what's in the picture it's the dog is
the cat right the second thing is face
detection so it will recognize that
there are multiple faces in the images
it will exactly point out where those
images are and even further than that it
will give you some impression if this
person is angry happy and so forth the
third one OCR optical character
recognition so basically it can
understand what text is in in the image
so it will read the text and it will
output it in text so you can actually
process it much easier it will also
detect explicit content like nudity
violence blood and it will give you an
indication this is a great feature if
you for instance in your application you
provide your end users to upload images
but you want to prevent that
inappropriate images are being uploaded
then landmark detection both natural
land war landmarks as well as human
created landmarks are detected and we're
going to show show you how what that
looks like and last but not least logo
detection so if you are worried about
copyright then we can actually detect
logos in any image and and and flag that
for you so how difficult is it well I
already mentioned it a single call so if
you look at this nodejs code it's you
have to include the google cloud library
of course you set up a configuration
JSON structure and basically there's one
call you provide the data you get you
specify a callback because you need to
handle the response that comes back and
that's it it's that simple so here's a
picture I took last year when I was
being a total tourist in New York it was
actually my first time in New York so I
spent a day just just walking around and
of course I had to visit the Statue of
Liberty right and I took this picture
and you can do this yourselves these
api's have demos on our website so I
just upload this picture on our website
and this one it came back so it
recognized the Statue of Liberty
correctly a gave a 55 percent confidence
rating and that's probably because I'm
on the the back backside of the Statue
of Liberty so it was probably missing
some distinctive features like the face
and the crown right so but still it
detected it it provided the location
where it where it is so that's landmark
detection this is what you get back from
the API right so now it's in a
programming language it's an adjacent
structure and you can process and
process it accordingly so here's the
face detection and I would like to ask
your special attention for the
expressionless Ness of my face in this
picture there's joy is very unlikely
sorrow is very unlikely anger spirit so
I I think I should pick a poker or
something like that but you will notice
it will act
provide where are my eyes why are my
eyebrows where's my chin it even gives
me suggestions on where to crop if I
want to use this for instance as a
profile picture it gives you the
dimension okay you should probably crop
it right there all right let's face
detection then label detections is if I
push the right button by the way this is
what you get back it's the same
information but then of course in an
adjacent structure then label detection
and I'm actually very impressed with the
label detection if you look at what it
gets from it well it gets a person well
I see that right but it also noticed
people in the background well it's also
pretty good look at this it thinks this
is a vacation picture which it was and
why does it do that I'm not really sure
probably the setting that it was the
Statue of Liberty and it's likely that
it was a vacation that there are people
there maybe the weather was nice and
look at this it picked up trifle
probably because I have a backpack it
recognized I have a strap around my
shoulder so this type of information
that you get from the label detection
and this is what you get back in Jason
and with the confidence rating and you
can act upon it as you wish all right so
I mentioned crop hints a very
interesting feature is web annotations
I'm going to show you an example of that
and another thing that we recently
announced an extension of or an
additional feature in the vision API is
a document text annotations and what
that actually does it is able to extract
large amounts of text so it's really
powerful for instance scanning scanned
document or if you take a picture of a
document or a large sign it will process
that that text correctly so web
annotations what's web annotation so
basically web penetrations provides you
additional information on where this
image resides on the Internet who else
is using it and that sort of stuff
so this car who recognizes this car yeah
what is it
that's great that's that's a car used in
the Harry Potter movies so it recognizes
what the car is but surprisingly it also
tells you that it's in the art Science
Museum in Singapore and it will also
provide that it recognizes this is from
the Harry Potter a Potter movie you will
also notice that you will find these
types of links here there and these are
references to the knowledge graph so you
can add an additional API call to the
Google knowledge graph to even extract
more information if you wish to do so so
then it finds okay where did this image
come from what are other places where
this image is currently stored and
perhaps there might be variants of that
image so maybe someone slipped it
horizontally or maybe someone cropped it
it was still detected all right like I
said all these api's you can try out
yourself for fun on our website cloud of
google.com and then for the different
API so go to vision speech natural
language and so forth alright so if
you're wondering how well did the vision
API with us
dogs and mobs pictures I think it did
actually pretty well so this it
classified this one as not only a dog
and a memo but it also noticed that it's
a common door breed so it goes even
further than just saying it's a dog and
for the rest this one also correct and
for the rest it almost got everyone
right so I don't know if this one is a
hit or a miss its fur yeah its fur but
okay it doesn't know if it's dog or any
other animal and textile and let's let's
say it's not correct so pretty pretty
good all right
so the second API I want to talk about
is the speech API so the speech API
basically writes what you're saying
right it's the technology that's behind
Google home it's behind voice search on
your phone and you can just include it
in your applications as well and we do
this transcription in over 80 languages
so a company that is using that as our
as our connects currently almost 20
billion people or has made almost
a billion connections between people
around the globe and they use the speech
API in a combination with the
translation API so that people in
different regions speaking different
languages can can hook up and can easily
communicate so let's see a demo so this
demo is is using the following it's
using a command line library called Sox
for the audio recording it's using a
bash script so it's one way to do it
we're gonna see some different demos
this is a batch script simply calling a
the REST API through a curl command so
we set up a JSON configuration and and
we'll send a request and we'll see what
it applies let's switch to the demo demo
please so talking to your machine at a
live stage that's always interesting so
as I said it's using different languages
so I'm gonna speak in in Dutch
this isn't demo strategy from the speech
API telling Google next all right so
this is the Jason that we prepared you
have to provide some additional
information to the speech API like what
is the format its flag what's the sample
rate being used you don't have to
specify the language then it will
default to English but in this case I'm
providing nlnl which is the locale for
Dutch and I'm going to talk about the
phrases context in a minute so let's see
what what the speech API actually comes
back with that's always interesting for
me all right so this is actually quite a
this is good because this helps me with
my demo so it says did this isn't demo
strategy from the speech C Phi Titans
Google next so it almost got everything
right and that's why we have that
phrases context because you might be
working with product names that might
not be very familiar in in the language
it might be a specific name and in this
case the API the word API probably in
Dutch we might say a P right so let's
head over to the code so this is the
code that is running that script and I
can give hints so let's add API as a
keyword to
the speech API so when we run it it will
actually hopefully better recognize what
I'm saying
all right that's right is again this
isn't Damon Scott see from the speech
API that is Google next you will notice
now that the confit has the API keyword
in there
yay success so now it correctly
identifies API as being a word so that
can be used in like I said for product
names or maybe specific words that you
want to look for in the speech API I
like to switch back to the slides please
so how difficult is it to call the
speech API well you will see the same
paradigm every time the same lines of
code you include the library it set up
the configuration do the call specify a
callback and that's that's it all right
so the third API that I want to talk
about I talked about it's the natural
language API so the natural language API
is aware speech translates it to text
now you want to do something with the
text right you want to see what is the
text about is it positive is it negative
what information can I extract from
these entities in the text and that's
exactly what the natural language API
does so one of our customers is woodrick
who's using the natural language API
they provide a customer satisfaction or
customer survey platform and their
customers use woodrick services to
solicit for customer feedback and they
do this in different way so they have a
typical scoring from zero to ten which
is you know very easy to get a sense of
is it is it positive or negative but
they also provide a free text field and
that's a lot harder right so what is it
what is it about okay you say it's eight
but is that what was what were you so
satisfied about so that's a lot more
more difficult they also use it to
basically do a consistency check so if
you say
three but in the free text you're
actually quite positive they can figure
this out and they think act upon upon
that also obviously they if you get
negative feedback you want to take
action right so they also provide
near-real-time routing off customer
feedback on to let's say a contact
center whether I can follow up they can
call the customer say hey we saw this
feedback we want to talk to you all
right so I've taken this from the
Wikipedia I'm gonna stay with the Harry
Potter theme I took this from the
Wikipedia page and let's see what
happens when we throw that at the
natural language API so what's
interesting it is it pulls Jo Ann Jo
Rowling JK Rowling and also Robert
Galbraith who is another pin named for
her for another book series and these
actually come back as the same entity
right so it knows this it will also
intervals it will know it's a person
here is again that M ID which is a link
to the Google knowledge graph where
additional information can be found
British it clearly identified it as a
location with a link to the United
Kingdom and obviously it gives it found
Harry Potter as an entity as well so the
second thing that the natural language
API can do so not only extract the
entities so what is this about but it
can also detect is it positive or is it
negative and it does so by providing a
scoring and the scoring goes from minus
one to plus one indicating whether it's
positive or negative but it will also
provide a magnitude and the magnitude
basically is an indication which goes
from zero to infinity is an indication
so how many text was used to being
positive or negative right so the more
text you provide negatively the number
goes goes up and that's also very
valuable to process
so the third thing in natural language
Apia does and maybe this is somewhat
helpful for for your application as well
is it analyzes the syntax so the first
thing it does it basically it creates a
dependency parse tree so it understand
what the relationship is between the
words and how they relate to each other
it will provide information on what the
word what the role of the word is in the
sentence so is it the root verb is it
the nominal subject that sort of
information it provides lemma which is
done for the word help here and
basically it gives back the canonical
form of the of the word so it will not
take into account different version of
of the word so you might have helps
helping help if you were counting for
certain words for instance you don't
want a differentiate between these
versions you want the canonical form you
want to use and count help and we're
gonna see that in a demo as well I lost
but not least it provides additional
information was it plural was it
singular and so basically morphology
information alright so let's see a demo
this demo I created in the following way
so basically what it's doing is I
subscribed to Twitter I'm looking for
tweets around machine learning Big Data
artificial intelligence those are sort
of keywords I'm passing every tweet that
I get back I pass it into the natural
language API to see if it's positive if
it's negative negative negative I store
this in to Google solutions so one is in
the firebase database which is a
real-time database that can be basically
I use that to get notifications whenever
it's changed in the database I get
notified notified in a browser so it's
very easy to see updates and I use
bigquery where I store all the tweets so
the firebase database only basically
keeps track of the last one and the
bigquery database stores all the other
tweets that I've followed if we can
switch to the demo
so here we see the front end so
basically the tweets are coming in live
on the big blue horizontal bar you see
the sentiment that it detects whether
it's positive or negative and so I ran
this yesterday and and then the numbers
came back and I'm looking for adjectives
by the way and surprise surprise if you
look for deep learning big data
artificial intelligence guess what the
most popular adjectives are going to be
deep big and artificial so well it's
working
but it's not a senseless data right so
you use it you will see that it the
natural language API was able to get the
tweet understand the sentence extract
the objectives the nouns count the
number of objectives and put out to
share this information I'm not showing
you twitch because you know what can go
wrong showing life tweets on stage I
mean here you see which is I guess more
interesting the the scoring whether it's
positive so generally speaking tweets
are relatively positive about about
these these things so that's that's the
fire base or there's a front end on the
firebase database let's switch to
bigquery so bigquery is our large-scale
data warehouse solution and so here I
store the tweets and I'm gonna scroll to
the right just to prevent strange tweets
being in there and so I store the tweets
I store some additional information the
user the time zone the number of follow
of course the hashtags very important
but here you will notice this huge JSON
string which is the output I get back
from the natural language API so looking
at this some of you might wonder if I
want to query this and we heard in the
keynote that you can use standard sequel
to query
how the heck am I gonna query this Jason
screen string and look for for these
function for these words well bigquery
supports a mechanism and let me open the
query for you oh sorry
where I can provide a user-defined
function so you can write your own
functions and include those functions in
your queries and actually we provide a
simple editor in the top here where you
can see that I specify the interface of
the function what it basically what it
expects and a right to function as well
and so basically what it does it takes
that jason it looks for objectives pulls
out the information and returns it as a
structure so now if I run this query
you will notice basically the same
results right so I can query this
information even if it's stored as a
JSON and the great thing is the power of
bigquery comes from parallelism right so
it distributes the query over thousands
of nodes and each node does this simple
thing and even these user-defined
functions are distributed across those
nodes to perform very well as well all
right if you can switch back to the
slides so this is how you call the
natural language API surprise surprise
same thing set up the config provide the
file set up a callback and that's it so
one of the newer features we've released
and now you see this now that that even
after we released these api's we keep
adding features to this API so we saw
the new features of the vision API here
you see a new feature of the natural
language API and this new feature is
called entity based sentiment so instead
of providing a sentiment over the whole
text we extract the entities and we
provide information what the sentiment
is of that specific entity in the
sentence so that's more powerful let's
look at this example I really like the
sushi but the service was terrible
so I'm positive on one side but I'm
negative on the other side so what am i
what am i positive about and what am i
negative about and that is provided here
as an example as well positive 0.8 is a
score and negative for the surface zero
and mine
zero-point-nine all right let's look at
translation API change the translation
API or the Google translation services
this is one of those very familiar
widely used functionalities it supports
the most languages hundred plus
languages and you can use it in your
application out-of-the-box so everyone
else Airbnb one of the customers that
are using the translation API basically
they 60% of their bookings is done in a
different language then that the posting
was in and they know that if you provide
the comments the conversations the
listing the additional information if
you provide that in a native language
then the chance of booking is much
higher so the translation API is
actually a very important component of
their of their offering so this is how
you call it
same thing and looking at the neural
machine translation which is the newer
version so basically last year we
released a new version of the
translation API and despite the great
work that the translation team had done
over the last eight or nine years it was
for them I guess may be said to see that
by the injection of machine learning
into the translation service it actually
gained a 40 percent improvement over the
quality so imagine we've been optimizing
and Google Translate was already pretty
awesome if you compare it with other
services but then if you already spend
so much time and effort in getting it so
at that level and then with machine
learning you get a 40% bump in the
quality that is huge that is huge so
that's the power of machine learning so
the old way it worked we didn't look at
the whole context so we basically we did
a word-for-word translation of the words
and we did recognize that there's some
relationship right so if it's singular
and plural we will adjust the verbs to
that
but it was basically that and with
machine learning translation we actually
take a different approach we've trained
a model with sentences and simple
sentences and to illustrate the
difference between the quality I've
taken this from the original Spanish
text of one of the Harry Potter's books
so when I say original I mean human
translated right the book was in English
it got translated by human meaning in
Spanish that's what I took and this is
the difference between the two
translation services so the first
generation translation it set things
like a company that made drills well if
it's making drills then it's a
manufacturer so the proper way to say
that would be it manufactured it and
necklace I don't even know if that's
actually a word necklace so without a
neck and almost twice longer than usual
that's kind of a weird way of saying
that in English right and we've all
played around with Google Translate I
assume and you understand what it's
about but you kind of go huh I wouldn't
like send it to my customer like that
right if you have that feeling have a
look at Google Translate again because
it is significantly better than it was
was before powered by machine learning
and luckily for you this API is
available and it benefits from the same
improvement as well all right so with
this demo I'm gonna do a couple of
things so I'm not going to do the speech
again but I'm gonna do a division so I'm
combining api's now because I think
that's the power of of these api's so
I'm gonna I'm gonna provide some text
just as an example take it to the
natural language API then I'm gonna send
it to the translation API and see what
the results are and I'm gonna do the
same with an image and the images of a
resume so if we can switch to the demo
please
all right so I've started up to demo so
let's start with some text
all right it's going to extract some
information so I'm not gonna output the
whole Jason because that will fill the
pages of the screen so I only took the
first word the first entity it found
this it says it's the nominal subject of
the sentence and it provides information
and for a lot of things this it doesn't
provide there's no gender in this and
that sort of stuff
but you will get that information for
all the entities in the world so I did a
sentiment analysis says you are pretty
awesome sorry you're a pretty neutral I
was supposed to say awesome in the
sentence and then it's God's going to
say that was great so this is pretty
neutral that's fine and the entities
found it found demo and it found
translation API now let's send it to the
translation API and I don't know if
anyone knows Spanish but hopefully that
is a pretty accurate translation just in
case I translated the translation back
to English so you can see what it came
back as so let's do this again but now
provide an image so in the image that I
that I have is this so this is an
example of the large amount of text that
is in the image that's one of the new
features of the vision API so this is a
resume it's just a sample resume a pool
of the internet it has a lot of text in
there let's see if the vision API can
actually grab that so I'm telling you
I'm providing a picture
it sends to the vision API and it
attracts a lot of information as you can
see let's see if it finds any entities
and it actually does of course so
there's a lot of entities in there so
for instance Jane worked at 3m
incorporated so I get a link to
additional information for that entity
as well and you see a lot of different
entities that are found in the text
let's translate it
so here's the resume in Japanese and as
I assume none of you speak Japanese well
maybe someone else and it comes back to
to English and you can see it works
actually quite quite beautifully so this
is an example of combining different API
so the vision API take it to the natural
language API to extract the entities
taking it to the translation API to
translate a document so you have
metadata from the natural language API
you have to translate the text so
everyone can read it and so forth let's
go back to the slides
alright so you saw the video
intelligence API briefly in the keynote
I'm now going to spend a little bit a
little bit more time about it so what it
does the video intelligence API is it's
our newest ml API so expect this to be
improved and enhanced over the coming
time what it does it provides
information of the video at different
levels so it provides it at video level
at scene level and even at individual
frame level one of the companies that is
using that is can't email consumer is a
company that provides services around
digital asset management and they loved
the video intelligence API because they
provide to their customers a servant's
surface where the customers can actually
search their extensive library of assets
so this is a quote from from the VP
product development thanks to the Google
cloud video intelligence API we have
been able to very quickly process and
understand the content of video down to
the individual frame with an
impressively rich taxonomy so let's take
a look at what it can do
so obviously the responses that you get
back is in is in JSON format so here's
an example of it's not telling us here
what is in the picture it's giving us
information about the framing how was
this frame this this scene shot and this
is a bird's eye view and as another
example
here it will recognize look this is a
portrait shot so imagine that you are a
video company in your make you have to
make video you can simply search ok give
me a portrait shot of something you know
a monkey in in the forest or something
like that and you will find in the vast
library of videos you will immediately
find that correct video I think that's
awesome
all right let's switch to the demo
so here I have the our demo for the
video intelligence API and let me make
it a little bit bigger and so I have
different videos and I can let's see
there was one that I thought was funny
this one a tour of Google and let's play
the video so the video starts there are
a couple of frames there pictures going
by then it starts as a typical video
there are some logos some signs and I'm
gonna stop the video here so you will
notice here that did spur and actually I
didn't see this at first and it's funny
how your eyes work right because I
clicked on one of the tags which was
bicycle and I had completely missed the
fact that there are bicycles in this
frame right because I I was actually my
eyes were drawn to this person walking
towards me
and I didn't see the bicycles but the
fact that my brain starts to focus on
certain things
that's something the computer you know
it's not bothered by it will just
analyze the frame and so here you see
all kinds of tags so there's a miracle
right there we have statues it found
that there's fruit which is correct and
I think here's actually the bicycle and
that's that's if I can see it yeah so it
takes me indeed to this to this to this
shot and I think that's very very
powerful so what we can do is we can
also do a search because we extracted
that metadata right we store that
somewhere now we can query it right so
we saw the example of beaches and I make
the same mistake because we have a
simple query there so here are the
scenes with which in there
see and if you're making a video you can
decide do you want the first picture or
the second picture different versions
different shots all kinds of information
and let's do another example let's say
baseball so when you're searching for
some videos then immediately from the
first line you will recognize well
almost this entire video is about
baseball right because the whole line is
it's pretty much red as opposed to the
last video where only a small snip
tidbit is is about baseball and if we
open that it correctly found that so I
think this is a very powerful way to
start working with with video and to be
honest this has been in a machine
learning processing video is one of the
hardest nuts to crack
why because if you look at an image it's
static right you look at the imaging you
process it but when you want to process
video you actually start looking in the
time difference story the time dimension
as well so you have to take into account
what is going going on so we go further
than just individual frames where we see
someone with a baseball we actually see
the movement as well all right if you go
back to the slides so how did we build
this demo so we're using a couple of
Google cloud services here so we store
all the videos in Google Cloud storage
that's our massive storage layer for
basically binary large objects so we
store it there and the great thing about
cloud storage and cloud functions is
that you can subscribe to changes in
your bucket so if something changes like
videos uploaded to your bucket
it actually notifies ha's cloud
functions and cloud functions is our
servers compute
service where you can write simple
pieces of code and in this case it tells
the video intelligence API
listen there's a new new video in this
bucket could you please process that
video with this ID it processes the
video and it stores the metadata in
another bucket so that is what it's
doing
then the front-end the demo that you see
is basically looking at both buckets so
it gets all the videos and it extracts
you know the metadata that is stored in
the other buckets so that's how that
works so as I mentioned before you can
play around with this you don't have to
set up a Google cloud platform
environment if you just want to try to
see how the vision API is doing just go
to one of these websites and play around
with with the demos that are available
there and last but not least if you want
to get a training and you want to get
certified on the different products of
Google cloud platform including big data
and machine learning we collaborate with
G company to provide training and we
actually have certifications for four
different levels of Google cloud
platform so there's a promotional code
for this event so if you go to G
company's booth they can provide you
with a promotional code to get to get
trained on these of these services if
you want to I have time for one question
if if there is one question yes sorry I
have one minute so anyway there's a
question over there
no at this moment that's not possible
but it's definitely a regal requirement
that we've heard so that might be a
improvement of the service that that
we're looking at no timeframe yet all
right yes and I'm happy to take
questions offline here of course that's
no problem and I'll be here all day so
feel free to to walk up to me and ask a
question thank you very much guys
[Applause]
you
[Applause]